le mont fuji c'est plus qu'une merveille
géographique c'est aussi un des symboles
du japon incident spirituel
depuis le xiième siècle ce temple shinto
est le point de départ vers le sommet
pour de nombreux pèlerins en quête de
purification les prêtres vénère l'esprit
qui habite le mont fuji
ils témoignent chaque jour de leur
respect afin d'éviter que le volcan
endormi n'entre en éruption ce prêtre
vient de passer un mois au sommet afin
d'accueillir les pèlerins et offrir ou
si une protection spirituelle ou
randonneurs car la montagne est avant
tout une destination populaire pour la
randonnée il campe un des gardiens
viennent de prendre notre température
est de nous inscrire dans un registre
pandémie oblige
nous sommes maintenant à 2400 mètres
d'altitude dans les nuages c'est ici le
point de départ de la randonnée pédestre
au mont fuji
un groupe se prépare à l'ascension une
douzaine de chants ceux qui profitent de
la réouverture des sentiers du mont fuji
après un an et demi
conséquence des mesures sanitaires
imposées au japon ce guide en est à sa
deuxième visite cet été il avait hâte de
renouer avec les sentiers qu'il parcourt
depuis plus de 20 ans dans le groupe le
rire et la fébrilité de kyo ppi sont
contagieux elles partagent l'expérience
avec deux amis la randonnée se fera sur
deux jours il faut donc être préparé des
nouilles déshydraté pour le souper ou
refuge en soirée et de la bière
évidemment tomoki lui a simplement hâte
d'arriver au plus haut sommet du japon
pour avoir une vue imprenable sur le
lever de soleil
en temps normal le mont fuji accueille
300 milles randonneurs chaque année les
sentiers ne seront ouverts que deux mois
seulement cette année l'ascension n'est
pas toujours facile mais qui oppose
savoure le moment à chaque occasion qui
s'offre à elle devra conserver des
énergies pour son arrivée au refuge bas
[Musique]
avec la réouverture du mont fuji une
aventure inoubliable s'offrent un
nouveau au japonais sur la montagne plus
sacrées du pays
copie peut en témoigner au dessus des
nuages le ciel est toujours bleu ici
philippe leblanc radio canada chine gogo
mais au japon